Netflix is set to unleash a wave of exciting
new content throughout the month of September.
Stuck on what to stream?
Here are the best movies and TV shows to watch
on Netflix in September 2020, plus everything
to see before it's gone for good.
In September 2020, Netflix subscribers can
go back to the Back to the Future film franchise.
The streamer introduced the full trilogy to
its digital shelves in May 2020, then removed
them in July 2020.
But just a couple of months later, Marty McFly
and Doc Brown will return to Netflix in their
complete trilogy glory.
Anyone who missed out over the summer can
stream all three movies beginning on September
1.
The sci-fi action fun doesn't end there, though.
Also headed to Netflix next month is Freaks,
You're One of Us, the action-packed, German-language
superhero film that follows working mom Wendy
as she learns she possesses powers of invulnerability
and super-strength, which were previously
suppressed by medication.
Wendy teams up with two other powered people
to seek out others just like them.
But their search soon grows complicated as
they end up uncovering a conspiracy bigger
than they ever thought could exist.
Freaks, You're One of Us hits Netflix on September
2.
Later in the month, catch the 2011 sci-fi
sports movie Real Steel, starring Hugh Jackman
as a former boxer whose life changes in major
ways after robots come to replace human combatants
in the sport.
Struggling to make end's meet by building
robots out of scrap metal, Charlie reunites
with his estranged son Max, and together,
they exact a plan that will put their names
on the map: create a bot that can become a
champion.
Real Steel will drop on Netflix on September
24.
In September 2020, Netflix is intent on making
sure that we all get the lion's share of laughs.
The first of the month alone gives us a few
modern classics, including 2002's hilarious
and heartfelt Barbershop, 2011's strip-tastic
Magic Mike, and the 2008 buddy stoner comedy
Pineapple Express.
There are also some more retro offerings on
the way for those who want to tickle their
funny bones on the way down Memory Lane.
There's 1993's Coneheads, which stars Dan
Aykroyd and Jane Curtin as the heads of the
clueless alien family they popularized on
Saturday Night Live, and 1978's Grease, a
timeless tale worthy of at least a dozen more
rewatches.
Other comedy selections include the 2005 film
adaptation of the Broadway play The Producers
with Matthew Broderick and Nathan Lane, which
hits Netflix on September 1; How to Train
Your Dragon 2, which arrives on September
11; and 2005's Waiting...which is required
viewing for anyone who has ever worked in
a service industry, popping up on Netflix
on September 23.
There's also the Cameron Diaz-starring Bad
Teacher, the 2011 feature about a…well,
subpar educator that drops on September 27.
"Alright.
Let's do this."
Those wanting even more laughs can stream
a quartet of new standup specials on Netflix
in September 2020.
Last Comic Standing season 7 winner Felipe
Esparza, whose previous specials They're Not
Gonna Laugh At You and Translate This aired
on Showtime and HBO, respectively, will make
his Netflix debut with Bad Decisions on September
1.
Then, on September 3, Brazilian comic Afonso
Padilha brings his debut set Classless to
the streamer.
Veteran British comic Michael McIntyre takes
over the spotlight on the 15th with a brand-new
batch of material entitled Showman.
And on the 29th, podcaster, actress, and The
Circle host Michelle Buteau unleashes her
new special, the aptly-titled Welcome to Buteaupia.
While there aren't a ton of new drama selections
heading to Netflix in September, the few that
we will see are worth watching.
There's 2018's Adrift, which stars Shailene
Woodley and Sam Claflin as a couple who must
navigate the treacherous waters of the Pacific
in a tiny, damaged boat after their yacht
is destroyed by a hurricane.
Then, 1989's Glory, an acclaimed Civil War
drama with a killer cast that includes Matthew
Broderick, Denzel Washington, Morgan Freeman,
and Andre Braugher.
And finally, 2018's Wildlife, Paul Dano's
directorial debut that follows the travails
of a troubled couple portrayed by Jake Gyllenhaal
and Carey Mulligan.
All three movies hit Netflix on September
1.
Sitting just beyond the realm of drama in
the mystery genre is one of the most highly-anticipated
films of late 2020: Enola Holmes, based on
Nancy Springer's Enola Holmes Mysteries series
of novels.
The flick stars Stranger Things' Millie Bobby
Brown in the title role, supported by a fantastic
cast that includes everybody's favorite British
super-hunk Henry Cavill as Enola's older brother
Sherlock; Sam Claflin (again) as her other
older brother Mycroft; and Helena Bonham Carter
as the trio's mother, Eudoria.
Warner Bros. originally had Enola Holmes set
up for a theatrical release, but Netflix acquired
the movie in April, and will release it on
September 23.
For horror fans on Netflix, there are some
cool new selections to cue up starting on
September 1, including the extraordinary 1998
B-movie Anaconda and the 2002 Silence of the
Lambs prequel Red Dragon.
But the ball really gets rolling on September
4 with I'm Thinking of Ending Things, the
new psychological horror film from Charlie
Kaufman.
The flick stars Jessie Buckley and Jesse Plemons
as a couple whose trip to meet the young man's
parents goes horribly awry.
It's hard to say what terror might ensue purely
based on the fact that the script for I'm
Thinking of Ending Things comes from Kaufman,
a truly original screenwriter who provided
the world with the cinematic mind-screws Being
John Malkovich, Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless
Mind, and Synecdoche, New York.
September 10 on Netflix brings us The Babysitter:
Killer Queen, the sequel to director McG's
obscenely enjoyable 2017 horror-comedy The
Babysitter.
Finally, on September 16, subscribers can
stream the hotly anticipated film The Devil
All the Time, the adaptation of Donald Ray
Pollock's 2011 Southern Gothic thriller novel
of the same name, with a cast that includes
Marvel Cinematic Universe alums Tom Holland
and Sebastian Stan.
"Excuse me preacher, you got time for a sinner?"
September 2020 will also bring plenty of good
stuff for TV binge-watchers.
All eight seasons of the underrated CW sitcom
Girlfriends is a pretty decent haul in and
of itself, and it'll drop on Netflix on September
11.
Fans of The Curse of Oak Island and Van Helsing
will finally get to binge the fourth seasons
of those shows on September 15 and September
27, respectively.
As far as Netflix original series go, hold
onto your butts: The first season of the amazing-looking
animated series Jurassic World: Camp Cretaceous
and the first season of the One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest prequel Ratched, starring
Sarah Paulson, both drop on September 18.
And heads up, foodies: The second season of
Jon Favreau and chef Roy Choi's The Chef Show
debuts on Netflix on September 24.
If you're one of those poor souls who missed
the fourth and final season of the widely
acclaimed NBC sitcom The Good Place, you can
finally remedy that unfortunate situation
on September 26.
"It's either this, or start Bloodline, and,
I don't know, I just don't feel like I can
see Kyle Chandler as anyone else but Coach
Taylor."
While many great movies and TV series are
arriving on Netflix in September 2020, the
streamer is still doing some housekeeping
and taking some options off the table.
In the first half of the month, subscribers
will say goodbye to all seven seasons of ABC's
fantasy drama Once Upon a Time, the first
season of Cold Case Files, the 2004 sci-fi
psychological horror-thriller The Forgotten,
and more.
The back half of September 2020 will see even
more removals: the South Korean action-horror
Train to Busan, the first and third Jurassic
Park movies, the underrated Heath Ledger flick
A Knight's Tale , and director David Fincher's
Oscar-winning The Social Network, a modern
classic movie which will celebrate its 10th
anniversary on October 1st, just a day after
it leaves Netflix.
"But you gotta come back.
Somewhere around the end of November, or early
December.
It's gonna be outta control, you gotta come
back for it."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.